waking up after an emotional argument
with your eye wings still on fleek so in
the previous episode nolan punched this
wall in a display of anger but does
punching a wall in anger give you any
kind of emotional release when you can
also punch through asteroids this has to
be like you or i punching through toilet
paper right here we see adam eve using
her powers to make coffee including
manually boiling the water look i still
don't fully understand what her powers
are and no i'm not going to research
them you nerd but can she not just
rearrange the atoms of the air itself to
create a steaming cup of morning go
juice instead of going through all these
steps why does she even need goat juice
coffee brand coffee pork you need to
trust me she does not debbie's
confronted nolan with proof that he
murdered the guardians so does he really
expect her to trust him that this was
all for the greater good just because
that's what obedient well-behaved wives
are supposed to do also this show's
beginning to soap opera so hard that i'm
having flashbacks to my grandmother
yelling don't you dare trust him at the
tv screen while stress-eating werther's
originals we'll talk later
nolan is addicted debbie two ceilings a
floor and a roof hey mark it's mom
listen to me i'm not around people that
do this with their voicemail come on
this is dumb yes diverting our attention
away from the main story to give us more
of this will they won't they
relationship b-plot is dumb
this is why i'm always late or why i
don't show forget interrogation or
torture the power of boners is
apparently all it takes for a superhero
to reveal their identity then why are we
fighting we're fighting because you lied
to me you made me feel stupid and
unimportant it's a secret identity mark
would be
that tv sends
so much for welcome back congrats for
not dying
premature being an ungrateful brat or
whatever the opposite of celebration is
indoor fireworks if the flying pieces of
superheated plastic don't get you the
unannounced ptsd inducing explosion sure
will that's a guarantee we're the
guardians of the globe baby if we can
die at any time uh
we can drink it anytime this logic is
not exclusive to the guardians anything
that's alive can die at any time and
anything that's alive can drink at any
time assuming it has a mouth a digestive
system and is of legal age to drink iced
tea now just give the show a sin for
acting like rex was capable of making a
good point but i'm lactose intolerant
whoa hold on do you know me at all i
filled them with beer i know rex is all
kinds of unhinged but this beer
situation must be addressed i don't care
how well he cleaned these gardens and we
all know he didn't there's still going
to be an unsettling amount of milk
switching around that beer why are you
never this industrious when it involves
training the manager at every job i've
ever had
i mean except this one of course can i
refill your coffee mr simmy i swear to
god he had his head on the bench and he
was just standing over it prying it open
with a phillips head screwdriver oh come
on no one's using a phillips head
screwdriver to pry open a complex piece
of machinery like robot's head you'd
obviously use a flathead for that
there
i am alone and helpless despite
two-thirds of the blue man group
acknowledging this is likely bullsh
they'll take baby robo at his word which
results in them being swindled gotta
love villains who are exactly as dumb or
as smart as the plot needs them to be
sorry love and sin are listed in the tv
since thesaurus is synonyms i'm a
terrible friend and a worst boyfriend
because i'm ah quick do the thing
you're like a bad guy in a samurai movie
who gets cut in half but thinks they're
fine until they're like oh my god my top
half's sliding away from my bottom half
one cheeseburger was harmed in the
making of the simile also putting the
cheese on the bottom bun instead of the
top of the burger like a society-hating
sociopath also also feeling about the
cheese and bun half of your bifurcated
burger instead of making sure you have
room for the heart attack in bun half
also also also what kind of monster goes
to the effort of setting out their
ketchup burger and fries only to leave
before eating a single bite of it are
there any heroes left in this world
velma dinkley doesn't have a bigger part
in this episode
there's a literal lorem ipsum text up
here on this monitor i don't know
whether to add us in for laziness or
remove a sin for ballsiness now i'm
lying i know exactly what to do there's
only one person i know who might be able
to go toe-to-toe with omni man and come
out on top debbie why would cecil think
that debbie is the best way to get to
adam eve wouldn't it be better to just
where's mark debbie no [ __ ] you robert
kirkman continues his crusade against
20th century innovators by using flat
head screws to do the hard work keeping
rudy's skull in place instead of the far
more useful cross head screws invented
by mr henry f phillips this procedure
doesn't transfer you to the new body it
creates a copy of your mind
let's just file that under things rudy
should definitely know already but thank
you for the clones position of course
this brain's abnormal
you didn't think of that look at it a
couple of things here one they only just
found out this is what robot actually
looks like so how could he have planned
for that and two you are literally his
clone so why didn't you think of that
too his motor cortex is the size of a
pea
same for his occipital parietal lobes
they've all been eaten alive by his
oversized cerebrum while writing the sin
i learned that the cerebral cortex is
the outermost layer of the cerebrum and
houses the four major lobes frontal
parietal occipital and temporal so
either thing one's description of what's
happened to robot's brain is not quite
accurate or brain surgery is way more
complicated than i think it is and i
should probably put this scalpel down
compensating now which apparently is as
easy as twiddling two wires together i
mean this repair job would have been
less ridiculous if he'd attempted a
simple percussive adjustment the
laughable idea that a progress bar
wouldn't quickly go to 98 giving the
illusion that it's almost finished but
then take an hour to reach climax after
four or five attempts and at least one
reboot electricity screaming fire
excitement i'm sorry it wasn't you i
think i understand the sentiment but
what a bizarre thing to be sorry about
in all the ways that matter he is him i
mean other than now occupying the body
of a younger version of a hero who he
didn't consult or receive consent from
before cloning but we've got the rest of
the season to explore there's only one
episode left and they're just pulling
this now and now that our deal is
complete
it's time you both return to prison if
fruity intends on taking them both to
prison why did he bother handing over
the schematics to the caller of course
the answer is that the writers needed
the roided smurfs to have the caller so
they can bring back the immortal
apparently the show was three minutes
short on run time and way under spent on
their animated blood budget rudy is a
genius but apparently that genius only
extends to making slightly bigger robots
judging by mark's choice of dartboard
placement a disregard for human life
must run in the family he's not dead
even after evacuating the neighborhood
we had to keep the yield down
best it'll do is knock him on his ass
for an hour or two holy sh cecil just
wasted a lot of people's lives
evacuating the neighborhood ahead of
time means he was always planning to
have donald blow that place so what was
the point of sending the soldiers into
the house at all if he knew that even
this explosion wasn't gonna do the job
what chance did they have texting and
flying so i'm helping you today seeing
all of this going on in the world but
deciding to help mark with his girl
problems perhaps after all this time
poor aim is actually a clone thing not
just a stormtrooper thing advantage
confusing cloning with telepathy i'd
argue even the slightest variation in
life experience would have an effect on
one's thoughts to the extent that the
longer each clone was alive the less
likely they'd be to be able to know what
the other is thinking but i'm not a
doctor so i'm gonna send this for being
a finishing each other sentences cliche
where's mark william
amber dumped him and he didn't like my
advice so he went to go find eve bullsh
does he know that it ended up being true
but mark stormed off without mentioning
a thing about where he was going if
you're gonna be labeled a snitch at
least be a factually accurate snitch how
do we know you're telling the truth ask
me something only robot would know
despite the sound logic of this idea
they forego any meaningful question and
answer segment making us all wonder why
it was even brought up in the first
place how the [ __ ] do you look like me
that is a much longer story one that can
wait it's actually a very short story
while in the body of a robot 30 year old
rudy developed feelings for a 24 year
old monster girl despite her being in
the body of a 10 year old he exploited
her attraction to rex by cloning his
body and transferring his consciousness
into it so that she'd fall in love with
him and they live a life of sciencing
together look i said it was short not
that it wasn't super [ __ ] creepy
can't you use your teleporter to bring
mark and eve back here you need to be
wearing one of these but it could have
rescued poor [ __ ] donald right you
wouldn't dare breaking the fourth wall
not even omni man she'll stop our sin
rays
[Laughter]
sorry but seriously why is omni man
making out like this laser beam is such
a big deal when he seems to have no
issues rick on starking his way through
it so he can blow up the source a
literal murder of crows 400 billion
dollars for the world's most expensive
nosebleed tony montana 1984. so you lied
to us about who you really were freed
the maulers from prison stole rex's dna
conspired with criminals to grow
yourself a new body and you expect us
all to be like oh sure who wouldn't well
yeah when you say it like that it sounds
pretty ridiculous however let's not
forget that the person pointing out said
ridiculous situation was written by the
same person who created said ridiculous
situation to begin with the world was
fine before i came along it'll be fine
without my help better probably i'm sure
it's likely a deliberate juxtaposition
but the mark is moody and miserable
about being a teenage superhero b-plot
really undercuts the fun of the catch
omni man a plot and now many minutes of
omni man being pummeled by mindless
robots who can't possibly hurt him yes
i'm both asking to get back to the
omniman action and sinning the omni man
action welcome to tv sins
further proof that every universe needs
an edna mode this creature is impressive
but it can't even fly so here's a sin
for all the other possible routes omni
man could and should have taken to get
past it
that should buy us five minutes or so i
mean you could have easily doubled that
if you made your move as soon as the
zombie robot soldier started attacking
instead of sitting back and enjoying the
show teleport me to invincible's
location cancer hail mary was so big
she'd burn off the teleport teleporters
more like teleplotters am i right it's
because they only work when the plot
needs them to
i'll move on get to guardians hq what
cecil listen to me and do what i say or
you could [ __ ] tell her that omniman
murdered everyone instead of playing the
situational equivalent of the pronoun
game with her also why is using adam
even the new guardians to take down
omniman the backup to the backup to the
backup plan instead of being the actual
plan if this creature does take out omni
man what the [ __ ] do they call to take
it out
a fight between a being we have no
reason to believe is even remotely
killable and another being who is
literally called the immortal and who we
have already seen die horribly and
return to life who needs stakes to keep
the audience invested when you have two
men punching each other really hard me i
do we need to talk we're all commercials
holy sh that actually worked this time
campers rise and shine and don't forget
your booties cause it's cold out there
it's cold out there every day i finally
rest
and watch the sun rise on a grateful
universe
were you were you blackmailed did they
threaten me or mark
no
then why
you need to trust me like sands through
the hourglass
so are the days of our lives
come with me if you want to live
no never
you can't where's mark debbie
where's waldo
[Music]
where's waldo
hello okay
new teeth that's weird
autobots
transform and roll out
i don't know it's kind of like we almost
finish each other's sentences
if you deliberately sabotage my band
i will [ __ ] you like a pig
now are you a rusher or are you a
dragger
that is a much longer story one that can
wait until whatever crisis this is has
been resolved by all means dr selden
speak
it's over nine thousand
you